Here in the US, the PCP as
gatekeeper is almost always used by
Health Maintenance Organizations or
HMOs.
There is data to show that this provides
better care quality at a lower cost.
Because of their key role in
coordinating care, HMO physicians almost
always have electronic patient
records and have for some time now.
However, HMO's also almost always
provide a more limited choice of
physicians as a means of cost control
and to facilitate managing care quality.
Marla, like many Americans,
gets Health Insurance from her employer.
At work,
she didn't select an HMO mostly because
she wanted a wider physician selection.
And she didn't like the idea
of someone deciding for
her if she needed specialty care.
She preferred to do that herself.
As a result, she doesn't have a PCP, and
gets all of her care
from many specialists.
Each of whom focuses on the problem
she has that is in their domain.